we're also learning tonight some members
of the unlv football team have tested
positive
chris will have a bit more on that
coming up in sports now
not all of our covid coverage is bad the
governor announcing some clarifications
for vocal performers today
they can remove their mask on stage as
long as audience members are at least 25
feet away
sasha loftus spoke with one local
comedian who says this whole process has
been really tough
on all local entertainers you know as a
comedian that's kind of you know
it's who you are for the last seven
months covid19 has pressed pause
on live local comedy do i really have to
make that call to the front desk
it's been a long road for many including
john caparulo
who was forced to close his popular
strip show
back in march we're waiting for them to
uh
you know to let us know you know when
they can who they see it sensible to
bring you know my show or anybody else's
show back
the state has since eased some
restrictions but the entertainment
industry
is still adapting the latest mandate
clarifies that vocal artists
can remove face masks on stage as long
as social distancing is maintained
i think they're excessive anyway but i
also think but it's also inconsistent so
it's really it's frustrating caparulo
calls any update a step in the right
direction
but believes rules should be clear from
the start
and fair across the board i think we
would all take this maybe a little bit
more seriously if
these restrictions were in any way
consistent but they're not
and until his operation gets the green
light
he'll join others across the industry
where we're going to be at the other
on the other side of this if there is
another side pushing for a safe return
to live fun sasha loftis 8 news now